jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen
zum heutigen video leute es kam jetzt
wirklich lange k minecraft mir auf
meinem kanal und ich habe nie so
wirklich erklärt warum kein minecraft
mehr gekommen ist und dies durch so von
jetzt auf gleich aufgehört habe und ich
will heute mal die ganze wahrheit
darüber erzählen das ding ist es ist
nicht so wirklich eine entscheidung
gewesen die von mir selbst ausgegangen
ist weil ich wurde in gewisser art und
weise erpresst kann man sagen
und zwar habe ich eines tages eine mail
bekommen eine geschäftliche e mail
adresse dass ich wenn ich nicht sofort
aufhöre minecraft videos zu machen
für immer und das in alle ewigkeit auf
jedem ein pvp server getötet werden
ein sparpaket keine ahnung warum dieses
intro jetzt am anfang war ich hätte lust
so einen kleinen job daraus zu machen
warum wirklichkeit minecraft kam
ich hatte schon ziemlich ziemlich lange
minecraft gemacht auf youtube und
irgendwie war das immer so mein ding
balkan crafter macht minecraft und es
ist irgendwie über die jahre immer mehr
so zur routine geworden dass man jeden
tag sich hinsetzt und minecraft video
macht und aus dem grund habe ich quasi
so das ende meiner schulzeit als
startschuss genommen dass ich einfach
mal anfange auch andere sachen vermehrt
zu machen auf die ich einfach zu dem
zeitpunkt mehr lust hatte das ding ist
minecraft pvp ging mir irgendwie als ich
zu der zeit wo ich dann aufgehört hat
mit mit minecraft videos ging mir das
ein bisschen auf die nerven
sobald ich hatte halt meine spielmodi
ich gerne gespielt habe bett wars sowie
games puck sg und sowas aber die sind
mir dann allmählich irgendwie soll ich
sagen
also eigentlich immer so ein bisschen
zur nase ausgegangen weil ich das jeden
tag für ein video gespielt habe und so
und es kam nichts neues was mich so
wirklich umgehauen hat
das ist eigentlich auch schon die ganze
begründung weshalb ich seid jetzt
mittlerweile glaube ich vier monaten
keine minecraft videos mehr hochgeladen
habe dafür mir ich bin ich jetzt einfach
mal diese erklärung schuldig weil ich
werde auch immer wieder in den
kommentaren gefragt hey wieso sollst mir
mit minecraft aufgehört macht doch mal
wieder minecraft für die leute die sich
wünschen dass ich mein kreuz machte habe
ich eine solche kleine ankündige wesen
die ihnen gefallen könnte und zwar kommt
bald wieder minecraft bevor die leute
denken die mich in den letzten monaten
abonniert haben wo ich ja kein minecraft
mehr gemacht habe entspannt euch
es kommt erst mal nur ein projekt ich
weiß nicht ob das projekt manche von
euch das sagt aber das heißt war hoch
einer trug also ich bin bei bravo dabei
war was das hat mir wirklich schon immer
dort gemacht weil diese war okay wenn
alle am anfang zusammen sind und so
aufgeregt sind das ist irgendwie war das
das ist unvergleichlich also hast du
beim nichts auf youtube umso mehr freue
ich mich dass ich dieses jahr wieder
dabei bin bei warum
und ich kann auch schon ankündigen dass
ich nicht alleine dabei sein werde
sondern dass ich mit luca in einem team
bin
das heißt das wird bei wago ein team
ausgeben
und ich denke weil es für ziemlich
lustig wenn ich mit lukas zusammen im
team wenn man verweise auch schon selbst
ewig kann mein kopf mehr gespielt und
ich glaube es wird ziemlich chaotisch
aber ich freue mich auf jeden fall schon
voll drauf weil ich habe darauf habe ich
lust auf so etwas entspannt ist nicht so
hart korting wisst ihr ach ja das war
schon das ganze video ja bis jetzt in
rund warum bei mir kein minecraft
meckern
hier ist auch das wieder minecraft
kommen wir jetzt zu bescheiden übrigens
morgen sollte die unbedingt wie ein
schwein auf meinem kanal denn morgen
werde ich die luft sprengen
das habe ich mir fest vorgenommen dass
das video morgen kommt und ich bin
überzeugt dass es ein echter hit wird
das video gut was kann ich sonst sagen
vielleicht spiele ich mich jetzt mal
wieder ein bisschen einen minecraft das
war irgendwie spannend wird dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten video wieder
und bis dahin und sorge dass jetzt so
dann kam ich habe irgendwie können
videos gemacht das ist unlogisch